Meem review we're back baby
just for one episode and then we're back
playing minecraft okay just gotta get
these memes out of the way then we're
back playing minecraft okay okay let's
do this
these are all gonna be a week old I've
been busy
September 20th what are you doing that's
right
raiding area 51 everyone who is
something is gonna read area 51
according to this Facebook group event
840 what thousand people are gonna raid
area 51
that's crazy storm area 51 they can't
stop all of us that actually makes a lot
of sense like what it again who if a
million people shows up what are they
gonna do okay finally we'll see all the
cool stuff like anime titties and stuff
we all meet up at area 51 alien center
tourist attraction and coordinate our
entry okay if when the route to run we
can move faster than their bullets what
I mean I can't argue with these facts it
truly truly amazes me here's some visual
representation of what that will look
like
[Music]
god damn it's going so fast in each our
little chat wishes like what is the
government sitting on in area 51 think
about it finally we will no no we're BS
me and the boys of September 20th
stirring Arabic big life
[Music]
and on one day for no particular reason
we just felt like storming area 51 you
know probably just like 10 50 people
like this will show up or everyone shows
up and it's awesome
come on gamers will drop the Nene in
front of the guards so stupid when you
get into area 51 and see another portal
what that would be awesome it's just
like stranger things and minecraft
combined oh my god
area 51 guard ma'am I can't let your son
inside Karen it's a matter of time who's
the manager of area 51 has anyone ever
asked that has anyone pulled that card
yet say there's a lot of ways to attack
here there's a lot of options but most
importantly what are we gonna get out of
this just think about the possibilities
like how I'm pulling up to area 51 how
I'm leaving in a hail of Warcraft
carrier that's awesome imagine just
pulling up to that in Burger King or you
could pull up to area 51 and you can
leave with an alien girlfriend okay
I can tell a couple of you are like
really getting into this okay alright
well I keep going then alright
area 51 will have kept girls you know a
little much is gonna be there he'll be
handing out flamethrowers to everyone
also guys make sure that you don't
forget to put down your bed in front of
an area 51 so that you can respawn in
case you and go bye-bye me finding out
my incognito browser history in a oh
what what but I'm incognito that we need
to store okay I'm signing up we need to
storm it now wait grande made it in oh
my god how did he do this I'm freaking
out
where the anime
what is the anime grande way matter this
better be good
okay alright top secret okay you're
really dragging this out grande it's
better be a hot minecraft girlfriend or
else I'm not I am out 300,000 US teens
stepping online munch wanna see some
alien alien dated what okay
now I'm in come on guys the government
sees people are going to infiltrate area
51 also the US government do you see not
fun they did not laugh I've got not this
what my alien I snuck out of area 51
sees when I tell him how to turn on a
light switch Bing bong mamee me my yeah
I think it was good time to take a break
Eric did not know I'm not watching this
I'm not watching this September flights
to Nevada skyrocket American airline
flights to Nevada an all-time high with
listen it's happening boys book your
tickets now come on dude there's a Del
Taco in there if he's the one how epic
is that all right I'm going I don't know
about you but I'm going there's 16
people who show up there you go it will
be 60 people area 51 300 I can't believe
it's already almost tripled Jesus the
genetically mutated prototype soldiers
the US government has been working on
Oceanside and area 51
we do have to think about what we
actually do inside there's gonna be many
bosses and battles when you manage to
store Arif if they want to find aliens
but you also end up finding something
else and they make girls would cut the
ears so could bite this nickel chair
named me and the boys escaping area 51
in fresh dude this could be us
Obama Trump a freak ton of us coming to
clap those alien cheeks
consensual of course when everyone wants
to storm area 51 but they forgot that
someone already did that
1982 ah that's beautiful I forgot about
that mission 10 out of 10 me well done
okay so oh yeah that makes sense here's
the battle plan the anti wax kids will
go first my route the runners go to the
side okay and the rest of us exactly
can't wait to see the awkward photos of
teenagers dress up in their route of
costumes going like oh this is cool well
done guys
area 51 meme gets at eight minus five
okay cool
next meme drop trump memes trump met up
with King Kong Owen again that's pretty
epic anytime there's news in the world
now the only thing that matters are the
memes let's get real here so truck means
kim jung-eun i don't know why i don't
know what they talk about all I know is
the memes my mom listening to my story
me explaining funny story my mom turning
it into a lecture me realizing I should
have told her story what I thought this
was only my mom sorry mom I don't want
to throw you under the bus but
apparently every mom just me my little
brother showing me his minecraft house
it's made of Minecraft memes are so much
better now that I play minecraft I just
had to have to watch Joe Joe Joe that uh
the guy who tried before me me having
just open a tight jar I loosened him up
for you what does he look like that what
is that face how do you just get that
face you gotta give him props for having
the best wrestling face I've ever seen
meuk me explaining how combining similar
formats will make the mean do better
my mom my therapist well played there
was also some really good photo shops of
Trump taking the first steps I play
minecraft so I understand this and I did
Oh drop was doing it as well with the
what's the level of double-crossing here
she belieber hop over and it's yours
wow thanks bro leveled one dude Trump is
about to get epically pwned it was a
great horse
yeah but we killed him I didn't know
president Trump and King young women
really cared thanks guys
not only not mr. beast and bless his
minecraft series now President Trump at
King jungle thank you very much thank
you very much guys I appreciate all the
support thank you for all the support on
the minecraft let's play serious it's
been a really epic time I rate this meme
[Music]
next me me VP Tiny's peepee bathwater
did you know that Belle Delphine sells
bathwater what so many news outlets
picked up on this like this is the talk
of the century she's selling birth water
wood and they all sold out Lizzie I know
you're all just pissed off that you
didn't get a chance to buy one gamer
girl bathwater but you really have
culture people here like lush sucks
asking the real questions
did you pee in the bathwater by any
chance like when is gamer girl peepee
coming out when his gamer girl peepee
poo-poo coming out okay let's get real
here listen let's ask the real questions
I don't want to drink water
that's disgusting I could die I'm gonna
drink gamer girl peepee poo-poo that's
what I'm talking about imagine drinking
gamer girl people you poopoo while doing
the stanky lake I'm pretty sure you
would become immortal or something like
that disclaimer this water is not for
drink you know damn well people are
gonna drink this
come on now this is more of my kind of
bath water I mean if you want to buy
Dell Belleville babe whatever this is
what I want this is what I want over 50
people have reportedly contracted herpes
after drinking back water I don't think
that's how it works but okay alright
what pyrocynical drank it oh my god
that's so embarrassing pyro pyro you
have herpes now he's got herpes
that's awesome stop posting the bail
Delphine bath
what a herpes story it's from a joke
account and you can't get herpes from
drinking water I should know I already
finished two bottles you just dragged
two bottles what are you crazy
what are you what are you nuts wait
tanners drank bath water yo yo yo
[Applause]
herpes juice okay I'll slurp give me
that her blemish dirt brah
we're talking finite rare limited
edition chicken farm water shipped
straight to your front door far more
than me minecarts prometheus gamer girl
behead the water but when is gamer girl
P coming out normal people h2o gamer
gamer girl P oh wow that's accurate I
think it's fun like she's clearly
trolling I don't know why people are so
mad about this I feel like if you're mad
you're equally bad as the people who buy
it on ironically that's just my take on
it Oh too pretty just a state of society
it said people drink bath water like no
I hope not
oh god remember to enter code pink why
would he buy your gamer girl pee water
and you can get 10% off tastes delish I
read bath water meme as a tune it's not
good okay guys it's been meme review
it's been fun
Calla weird to be back and doing
different stuff but minecraft come out
tomorrow and if you want to be a real
gamer we have new minecraft gamer merch
for gaming week exclusive we got Jurgen
beautiful long sleeve real tribute to
Jurgen we also have spent church protect
at all costs check it out support
channel and as always thanks for
watching have a nice day
no brofist because I am what you never
play to / simulator you know it's fun
right I'm not supposed to give my
opinion but give it a try and then you
can tell me if it's
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]